strategic uh project manager at uh varis
analytics uh she also uh a dog rescuer
in her spare time uh please welcome to
Stage uh pradna all right everyone uh
hello my name is pradna I am Senior data
engineer manager at verisk analytics in
strategic projects but today I'm not
going to talk about projects I'm going
to talk about products which is most
important
right
so in this picture you can see a
beautiful home in the middle of the sea
let's imagine this is your data product
and you hire a team of data scientists
to build doors for your
product you go to your data science
leader and ask them hey can you build
doors and the data science leader yes
that's our expertise we can build the
world's best doors and then the time
deployment time comes and you realize
that door doors are not fitting right to
the house and the success metric of this
product is how many houses pass the
eligibility criteria so if the door is
not fitting right then the product is
not going to pass this eligibility
criteria so how do we make sure that the
doors that we are building are helping
our products to meet these success
metrics the first step that we go with
is we look into the development product
development or operations whatever you
call it and we started digging into it
when you think about operations what is
the first thing that comes into your
mind back office business as usual
business as usual is like our favorite
word at my company and yes and you
remember that there are set of people
who who are doing same job day in day
out right that's nothing really fancy
about it truly operations is the heart
of the product that is the vertebrae of
your organizations who's is bringing in
Revenue day in day out it's very
important and operations are also are
one of the top costs if you look at the
financial statements of your
company these operations are consciously
designed systems by the engineers but
these engineers and the functional
managers are too busy in meeting their
day-to-day deadlines they have no time
to think about how to do the existing
thing in a newer way and the Innovation
Center or the R&D units of your company
may have their own objectives for the
future of the company like the AI they
have their own budget so there is no
ownership of innovation in operations in
most of the
organizations but you might think don't
we have pmo program management office in
uh in big organizations who are
responsible for these kind of initiative
yes pmo are responsible for doing work
faster reducing task error automation
that's our favorite word but uh and they
are supposed to report cost savings to
the CTO coo whoever that leadership
is
however today I'm going to tell you if
you lead a transformation from a product
perspective of your operations you will
see a different way of doing things you
will start seeing things from the
product point of view and not from a
specific operational point of
view I'm going to give you example of my
own
company uh we are Insurance analytics
Solutions we provide uh insurance and
itic solutions to our business partners
and this is the example of one of the
products it is named as
circulars it provides prospective loss
cost to our to the insurance companies
and as you can see this is a very simple
example of our system it is much more
complicated however you can see there is
team of acturial there is team of data
analytics team acturial act as smes in
our company and then we we also have
data science team who manage two
different machine learning models we
have different data sources and then we
then the product is produced and then it
goes through compliance production and
then it is released to the customer on
our digital platform which is developed
by Our IT team and this
operation
oper hello okay we have this operation
for 20 plus lines of business so you can
imagine how crazy it can get and this
operation was designed mind keeping
customer in
mind keeping customer in mind uh almost
10 years ago in our
company
we as expected as it is saying but in
reality it looks something like
this okay thank you so you can see the
first major problem the customer is
having hard time in ing the data out of
the reports we deliver reports in the
PDF formats and when we when this
product was produced this product was
meant to be for the executive level so
it not only includes figures and data
But it includes lot of words so it is a
report but then our customer evolved
they started using the data out of that
report for their own technical needs or
whatever the products they are producing
and then you can see there is another
issue that that we are receiving
frequent ad hoc request for the state
level loss cost analysis which is adding
extra workload on our actual team data
analytics team data science team and
other entities so how did we address
this issue and what did we do about
it first we listen to the to the
customer we did a customer surve and we
realized that major of our customers
want to see the state level prospective
loss cost in digital format so our team
decided that we are going to deliver
customer what they
need however whatever product management
decides it doesn't it is very difficult
to implement because of the complex
system that you can see so for the pilot
of the product we did created a separate
data analytics unit that was producing
these uh these uh Statewide Prospect
prospective loss cause in digital format
and we thought that this is going to be
a temporary data analytics solution
because the work that was needed for the
data processing and data analytics was
very laborous because of the complex
data system the one of the ma many
challenges that we faced was Finding
origin of the data we didn't do a good
job in tracking data langage
traditionally and uh when we were look
taking the look at the higher view of
this entire operation we realize there
are so many different gaps but the major
elephant in the room is our data storage
we have a massive data all over all over
the world in fact our teams are
despressed uh
geographically and uh they have their
own work culture there are no
standardized process of uh even machine
learnings are like machine uh these
models are not managed in a in in a
standardized format so everybody's doing
that their own thing they have no idea
what it is serving the what is the
higher purpose of it so uh two and a
half years ago we started this
initiative of creating single source of
Truth you must have heard yesterday
right is it has uh it has a great
benefits so um we didn't start our this
Innovation this part uh with with
bringing all the lines of business on
board very difficult child uh difficult
things to do we started with only few
lines of business and we thought that
okay let's we will see what are the
different challenges that we will face
when we are creating this single source
of Truth for a few lines of business and
then we will expand to the other lines
of business to a uh cut down two and a
half years later that is today we have
six lines of business major lines of
business which are uh which are serving
as a single source of Truth and guess
what it not only helped this particular
product not even the innovated product
it has helped 100 plus products because
we came to know there are so many
products that are dependent on that data
source and now everybody wants to uh get
on board now we have apis we are using
kindnesses for the data streaming
purposes and it's just amazing our
system is not only flexible it is ready
for the next market demand now in know
uh building new product is not as
difficult at as it was
before this is a simple illustration of
a data product operation you can see
bunch of producers machine Le uh machine
learning Engineers data
Engineers uh actural Engineers whatever
you want to call them they are producing
something and there are stakeholders
internal stakeholders who are receiving
something this something is nothing but
data but in different form so actually
we are all service provider at
individual level We Are We should strive
to uh strive to satisfy our internal
stakeholders trying to understand their
needs and that's when you will start
seeing your day-to-day job
differently our goal should not be only
producing worldclass product and adding
new feature our goal should be out
operating your competitor because that's
your spine of your
organization so bringing any operational
change is going to have is going to have
outward ripple effect enterprise-wide uh
so these kind of changes are going to
affect the smallest entities which are
not really visible to you even the
customer rep can be get can get affected
even the production people can get
affected so when when we are we are data
science Community we kind of focus on
building models but there are other
things that happen on the other end
until that product reaches to the
customer so these kind of changes are
are not really welcome uh by executive
level because they have to face lot of
resistance they uh the uh they have to
say yes bringing different people on
board is quite challenging what you can
do to get started is try to identify
accelerators accelerators are nothing
but the set of people who are leading
and pushing medium scale small scale
Improvement all by themselves there are
self motivated individuals these are the
individual who who knows the grassroot
level inefficiencies these individuals
are not perceived as Leaders so people
are kind of really open to them about
the issues that they are
facing one thing that you can do is
developing a prototype solution and Sh
show a demonstration to your SE suit so
that they will know what kind of
positive impact you can bring with your
Innovation
idea applying design thinking and
connecting different processes together
until the final product is produced will
help you to understand uh your
operations not only at higher level but
you will uh you will get to know what
are the smallest entities that are
involved in the in the entire products
operation you truly have to see your
work as a product not as a project you
have to see your work as a product and
act as a service provider a data goes
through thousands of uh touch points
before it becomes a final dashboard or a
report and served as a c served to the
customer at in in this thousand uh touch
points there are several humans involved
human plays a very key role in all the
aspects machines are not building
machines machines are not running
programs we are writing those programs
we are we are building those machines so
we have to give this due importance to
the human factor and the impact that
bring that they bring on the uh on the
operations and one thing is important to
understand that there is a difference
between projects and product when you
start looking at your work as a project
project has is a short-term goal project
has an end point project is supposed to
add value to the product they are not
supposed to develop the product so
changing that mindset from Project to
product is very much
important if you want to become a true
strategic business partner to your
business you have to stop seeing your
operations as a traditional order
fulfillment
system getting started can be
challenging but you can start uh
benchmarking against your industry try
to check what are the different uh
technological uh innovations that are
happening there is generative AI we all
know about that then there are there are
superb uh orchestration flat platforms
for scheduling your jobs there there is
this data streaming and microservices
right now available in the market try to
explore then uh second thing is
empathize with your internal customer
try putting yourself in their shoes try
to understand their work Dimensions what
are the important key factors of the
products that you deliver that matters
to them what are those important
variables that they look at before they
they they do their job and move it
forward try to understand those uh those
points look for non value adding
activity my favorite one is business
weight times handoffs we are all there
is such a there is always a lot time
between different business areas try to
address that what are uh something like
non underutilized Talent we do not have
time uh sometimes we hire people but we
we do not have time to train them try to
identify those issues once you find out
the problem do a thorough root cause
analysis uh root CA my favorite method
is five wise method root cause analysis
is very much important and you have to
spend a good amount of time in doing
that because you want to address root
root problems not the surface ra
problems here try think like a s Like a
Surgeon you do not want to put bandages
on the system you want to fix it system
from the
core and then uh prioritize prioritizing
is very very much important we are
thinking from the product perspective we
should always prioritize only those
problem which are important to the
business and not to the operation not to
the area important for the business that
is very much
critical and one more thing I would like
to add is versioning your solution uh we
all know who are in machine learning we
we are creating new models we are
creating new features we are releasing
new models and we all version the models
but what about the other activities of
the data analytics what about those
programs that we are that are necessary
for the data processing right I always
tell tell my folks is like just create a
bare minimum program it doesn't have to
look the best looking program the
cleanest code at all do deadline zoom
out see if that is fting in with the
other entities in the business and then
go back and make it better that will
give you a better perspective and that
will save you a lot of
time when we focus on operations it has
higher impact at the product strategic
level you will uh you will save lot of
money in the operational cost that can
go till millions of dollars but that
will that will give you an opportunity
to set the competitive prices uh you
will achieve business agility your uh
your processes and your operations will
be ready for the next market demand and
the next technological there is
generative AI is coming and we God knows
what is going to come next so you have
to be as agile as possible and you
should have your operations and train
your uh your human force to be agile and
uh be uh and utilize those latest
technology then there will be higher
customer retention rate you uh
that will be a different differentiating
factor from your competitor not everyone
thinks about operations because
everybody wants to bring in the latest
technology but as I said humans are very
much important you should concentrate on
changing their mindset and when you
start this initiative which could be
years like it our initiative is two two
and a half years later it's haven't yet
completed but it could take a lot of
time to to come there but the uh but the
reward it's going to be much more
because your your human force is going
to be full of cous mind that their
mindset will be changed people will
think will start thinking from the uh
from the product perspective from the
revenue perspective and you will see
those difference
immediately so that's it from my end I
hope this talk inspired you and nuded
your brain to make some little changes
in your operation
and uh you can connect with me on
LinkedIn and let me know I would like to
uh hear your stories and your business
as usual problems we all have all right
thank
you